[Musique]
merci Valérie léthard de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu du Nord du
groupe Union centrée c'est vous avez été
lucénatrice pour la première fois
c'était en septembre 2001 vous avez
choisi de ne pas vous représenter vous
nous direz quel bilan vous faites de ces
plus de 20 ans de mandats de ces 22 ans
même s'ils ont été un petit peu
entrecoupés on va voir ça on va revenir
bien sûr dans quelques instants sur tout
votre parcours mais d'abord on va parler
des sujets d'actualité et d'abord c'est
l'immigration puisque cette tribune
conjointe de parlementaire de la nuque
et de l'aile de la nuque et de l'aile
gauche de la majorité a été publiée hier
pour rappeler à la régularisation des
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
initiative et
elle mérite d'exister et en tout cas
elle rappelle le débat sur l'immigration
qui est sous-jacent actuellement dans
l'actualité politique et dans les textes
qui doivent arriver je rappelle que
au-delà de cette tribune le Sénat a déjà
pris le dossier à bras le corps puisque
avant l'été avant que la réforme des
retraites ne vienne un peu bouleversée
les choses il y a eu un texte le texte
immigration tel qu'il existait donc
avant l'été qui a été examiné par la
commission des lois et qui a fait déjà
l'objet d'un premier rapport et qui a
permis en tout cas à cette assemblée de
voir effectivement comment cheminer il y
a déjà des propositions qui avaient
émergé et effectivement parmi ces
propositions il y a un sujet l'article 3
de ce texte qui porte effectivement sur
la régularisation des personnes en
situation irrégulière sur mes métiers en
tension et sur ce sujet là effectivement
il y avait quelques différences quelques
divergences d'appréciations d'analyses
sur les risques d'une telle
régularisation d'appel d'air ou pas et
là-dessus d'entre vous les centrices et
les républicains les républiques c'est
leur ligne rouge vous vous êtes
favorable c'est à dire que on a une
différence analyse en disant il y a un
principe de réalité c'est une réalité il
y a aujourd'hui énormément de
travailleurs en situation irrégulière
comment on fait pour prendre en compte
cette réalité c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on
est en capacité est-ce que ces personnes
ont vocation à retourner à être conduit
à la frontière est-ce que c'est une
réalité est-ce qu'on considère que si
elles sont sur le territoire depuis
plusieurs années ce qui était un petit
peu le sujet dans le texte
elles ont vocation peut-être à venir
être régularisée au travers d'un titre
de séjour mais un titre de séjour c'est
une autorisation temporaire qui n'enlève
pas leur statut de personnes en
situation régulière il le stop pendant
un moment mais ça veut pas dire que
c'est le père de leur emploi elles ne
retrouvent pas ce statut et non pas
vocation effectivement
la question c'est comment sécuriser un
sujet comme celui-là on n'est pas
d'accord pour une régularisation sans
condition et sans regarder quoi que ce
soit on sait qu'il peut y avoir des
risques mais en même temps on a des
métiers en tension on a énormément de
salariés qui sont dans cette réalité de
salariés sans papier on a peut-être
regarder comment sur cette question on
peut cheminer il existe aujourd'hui une
circulaire valse qui permet au Préfet de
régulariser au coup par coup ces
situations mais elle est mal écrite elle
est obsolète et elle ne correspond pas à
la réalité peut-être penchons-nous sur
quelle solution pourrait trouver une
convergence de vue parce qu'on aurait
sécurisé quelque chose qui quand même
doit être traité c'est une réalité il
faudrait peut-être garder je sais que
mon collègue Philippe bonnecarer avait
fait des propositions c'est à dire un
rapport annuel plafonné le nombre de
personnes qui pourraient être
régularisées et faire attention aussi à
ce que pourquoi des métiers sont en
tension peut-être qu'il faut revaloriser
ces métiers et qui a un travail à faire
aussi avec les partenaires sociaux pour
qu'à terme on est plus besoin on ne se
retrouve plus dans cette situation où
des personnes en situation irrégulière
occupent des métiers que personne ne
peut occuper parce qu'ils ne sont plus
attractifs c'est un sujet sur lequel la
vérité est pas écrite d'avance c'est un
sujet sur lequel on peut trouver des
consensus et le Sénat c'est le faire ça
veut dire que vous êtes optimiste sur un
consensus sur ce texte vous vous venez
d'une région où le rassemblement
national fait de fait des scores très
haut est-ce que ne pas trouver un
consensus sur ce texte ça ferait le jeu
du rassemblement national
moi je pense que il faut pas ignorer
l'inquiétude en fait je pense que les
Français aujourd'hui
savent très bien que on a une
immigration qui est là qu'elle a déjà
existé il y a eu des vagues migratoires
moi je viens quand même d'un territoire
justement le Nord-Pas-de-Calais qui a pu
développer son industrie on a eu besoin
de faire appel à des vagues migratoires
à des immigrés à des moments où on
n'était pas capable de trouver la main
d'oeuvre supplie une fusion dans notre
territoire
il dit il a rien du extréalisation de
pays ne sera pas sans l'immigration oui
d'accord avec simplement simplement
les Français aujourd'hui ils ont
l'impression qu'on la subit cette
immigration qu'on ne l'a choisi pas je
pense qu'on doit être capable de mettre
un cadre et de savoir maîtriser notre
politique migratoire qu'il faut
constater quand elle y a des réalités
comme ça mais on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi il faut que le cadre soit
clair net et précis et que on sache
expliquer aux Français que si on fait ça
c'est pas ouvrir la boîte de Pandore moi
je dis pas il faut faire où il faut pas
je dis juste c'est un de réalité moi je
n'y suis pas défavorable du tout parce
que c'est une réalité mais on ne peut
pas être irresponsable sinon là on fait
le jeu du Front national mais on a le
devoir de travailler sur une solution
qui soit solide sérieuse qui ne soit pas
irresponsable il y a une réalité
attention à ce qu'on fait on doit
encadrer les choses cette ce sujet de
l'immigration ça fait partie des sujets
qui ont été abordés entre Emmanuel
Macron et les chefs de parti dans ce
qu'on a appelé les rencontres de
Saint-Denis Emmanuel Macron avait
demandé aux parties de lui répondre
avant Dimanche soir vous êtes membre de
la direction de l'UDI vous pourquoi
l'UDI n'a toujours pas répondu d'abord
parce que
l'UDI a toujours travaillé en consultant
énormément les acteurs de la société
civile les corps intermédiaires le monde
du logement sur les questions du
logement qui sont majeurs
le délai de prendre notre temps on peut
pas répondre voilà on a une commande on
a 15 jours pour rendre une copie bah oui
sauf que sur des sujets comme la
décentralisation non seulement on va
consulter les corps intermédiaires et
tous les acteurs de la société mais on a
aussi ici un travail qui semaine par
exemple avec nos collègues sur les
questions décentralisation ici au Sénat
un regardons un petit peu comment nous
nous cheminons aussi sur ces questions
le président de la République nous
questionne sur ces sujets non on a des
idées très claires et on commence à
travailler à des propositions essayons
de coordonner aussi la façon dont nous
voyons les choses mais en tout cas je
peux vous dire que sur la
décentralisation rentre de l'autonomie
au collectivité
rendre sa passe aussi par peut-être
rendre une fiscalité des moyens propres
collectivités la loi de décentralisation
qu'est-ce que c'est un état qui contrôle
l'application et la légalité de ce que
font les collectivités et des
collectivités qui sont des partenaires
de l'État pas des agents de l'État c'est
une c'est permettre à des collectivités
d'être au plus proche de la réalité de
ces concitoyens sur des sujets qui font
la vie quotidienne des gens aujourd'hui
rendons ces lettres de noblesse à la
décentralisation que l'État fasse
confiance aux collectivité plutôt que de
leur expliquer et de les prendre pour
des
voilà pour des gens pas capables de
tenir une ligne et d'être responsable
une collectivité elle rend un budget à
l'équilibre collectivité elle doit avoir
les moyens d'être au rendez-vous de ces
concitoyens rien que ce sujet là pour le
Sénat il est majeur et il a un impact
immédiat sur la population le logement
demain il faut qu'on soit capable de le
prendre à bras le corps il faudra lui
donner des moyens on parle de donner le
logement collectivité en compétences
avec quels moyens avec quelle levier
avec quelle dynamique oui à condition
que le jeu ne soit pas un jeu de dupe
Valérie il est tard on l'a dit dans les
prochains jours vous allez quitter le
Sénat après 22 ans de mandat et beaucoup
de combat portés pour votre territoire
pour les territoires et les élus pour la
réindus réalisation le logement le
social mais aussi pour les femmes on va
revenir avec Audrey vuettaz qui s'est
plongé dans les archives de votre mandat
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour Valérie
bonjour et Audrey vous êtes plongé dans
les années sénates Valérie Létard mais
pas que parce que Valérie léthard est
montée de nombreuses fois au plateau on
va en parler en tant que vice-président
du Sénat mais vous l'avez retrouvé qui
monte sur les planches et oui vous
rappelez de quoi je vais parler nous
sommes en 2008 vous êtes secrétaire
d'État aux solidarité dans le
gouvernement de François Fillon Valérie
Létard un intermède dans votre mandat de
sénatrice et ce soir là vêtu d'une veste
rouge armée de sang-froid il faut il
faut le dire vous montez sur scène pour
prononcer un texte militant les
Monologues du Vagin on regarde
ma mini-jupe est un tourbillon sauvage
une bouffée d'air un pas de tango la
mini jupe est une initiation une
impression
une partie de l'argent récoltée ce soir
là sera utilisée pour venir en aide aux
femmes victimes de violences ça fait
écho à l'un des derniers textes que vous
avez porté ici au Sénat une aide
universelle d'urgence pour que les
victimes de violence conjugales puissent
quitter au plus vite leur domicile un
texte voté à l'unanimité au Sénat on le
rappelle l'émancipation des femmes
c'était l'un de vos combats votre combat
et vous savez enfin il a pris d'ailleurs
le dessus dans ce pays c'est devenu la
grande cause du quinquennat on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui la parole s'est libérée
et qu'on a pris toute la mesure du
chemin qui reste à parcourir pour
effectivement accompagner la possibilité
pour une femme et bien de reprendre sa
vie en main et de ne pas subir
effectivement une situation de violence
physique ou psychologique et que et bien
il est
urgent de continuer à construire une
solution dépend de solutions existent
tout le monde se mobilise mais pour
accompagner une femme dans ce long
parcours selon chemin très complexe qui
permet de s'extraire d'une situation de
violence c'est encore plus compliqué
quand il y a des enfants et bien il y a
des maillons qui manquent dans la chaîne
il y a des moyens qu'il faut continuer à
organiser à imaginer à inventer et au
travers de mandats locaux et de lien que
j'ai pu garder entretenir avec des
professionnels sur le terrain du monde
associatif des travailleurs sociaux on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait un vrai
sujet c'est que quand une femme
lorsqu'elle est vraiment un stade avancé
des violences lorsqu'elles subit des
coups lorsqu'elle est amenée à faire un
dépôt de plainte lorsque un signalement
est fait au procureur de la République
et bien quand vous quittez votre
domicile en général on essaye de quand
vous avez pas de solution familiale de
vos orienter vers un hébergement un
accueil d'urgence et il peut se dérouler
un mois deux mois trois mois avant que
vous puissiez rebondir et trouver des
ressources quand vous partez d'une suite
à l'autre sans argent sans papier sans
moyens avec vos enfants à la main et que
vous devez attendre un mois à trois mois
et qu'on on vous accompagne dans une
structure d'accueil d'hébergement c'est
très difficile et beaucoup de femmes
renoncent beaucoup de femmes capitulent
et au bout de 24 48 heures et bien elle
rentre à la maison parce que c'est trop
dur et bien il y a au travers de cette
aide d'urgence la possibilité sous 72
heures de pouvoir aller chercher une
aide financière qui est non remboursable
lorsque vous êtes en situation de
fragilité et qui serait remboursable
mais d'abord par le conjoint violent
lorsque celui-ci est solvable c'est à
dire qu'on va c'est pas la victime qui
va rembourser ce prêt lorsqu'elle est
effectivement
et bien elle a des enfin voilà quand
elle doit le rembourser sachez que
normalement cette tête d'urgence elle
n'est pas remboursable parce que lorsque
vous êtes dans une situation de
précarité elle sera prise en charge par
la caisse d'Allocation Familiales ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'elle était
attendue qu'elle a été avec les
professionnels mais que maintenant et je
profite d'être ici avec vous le
gouvernement avait demandé 9 mois pour
sortir les décrets d'applications la loi
elle a été votée en février dernier donc
je profite d'être là et de passer un
message au gouvernement à notre nouvelle
ministre en charge du droit des femmes
s'il vous plaît chaque mois qui passe
c'est un mois ou ça ne peut pas
s'appliquer tant que les décrites
d'applications n'ont pas été sorties si
le gouvernement alors que nous sommes
dans la grande cause du quinquennat
pouvait faire en sorte de créer les
conditions et donner les moyens à la CAF
pour qu'elle puisse bien mettre en
oeuvre cette aide universel c'est le
moment normalement en octobre il
faudrait pouvoir le faire je sais que
c'est pas facile mais il faut qu'avant
la fin de l'année on ait pu concrétiser
cette solution qui est fortement
attendue sur le terrain alors une aide
universelle inspirée par le terrain vous
l'avez dit en circonscription dans le
Nord votre territoire c'est d'ailleurs
là que tout commence pour vous vous êtes
assistante sociale à Valenciennes et
vous faites une rencontre en 95 celle
d'un certain Jean-Louis Borloo qui est
mère de la ville il vous propose un
poste d'adjointe mais il faut dire que
c'est pas votre premier contact avec la
politique votre père Francis de coréen
exécuter européen président du club de
football de Valenciennes est une figure
de l'UDF on vous voit d'ailleurs tous
les trois j'ai retrouvé un extrait où on
vous voit en train de couper un ruban
question qui vous donne le déclic l'un
ou l'autre ou peut-être pas aucun des
deux qui vous donne le déclic d'aller en
politique déjà des clics moi j'ai grandi
dans un univers où la chose publique
plus que la politique politicienne j'ai
un grand-père qui a été maire d'un tout
petit village avant la décentralisation
ou en fait le maire d'un village il
allait mettre le chauffage en route dans
la salle des fêtes et réparer les trous
dans le toit de l'église en fait c'était
ça mais où on parlait de la chose encore
souvent le cas et ce qui est encore le
cas parce que malheureusement au moins
les moyens sont au rendez-vous et plus
les maires des petites communes sont des
bénévoles de la République donc moi les
votre famille on parlait toujours de la
chose publique ça doit toujours
passionné et avec enfin voilà cette
vision vraiment mon père s'est engagé
aussi il a toujours été passionné il m'a
donné en tout cas j'ai grandi avec cet
appétence et puis en 91 enfin 89
Jean-Louis Borloo était élu à la mairie
de Valenciennes j'étais moi déjà une
professionnelle de la politique de la
ville donc c'est tout début quand elle
elle était créée et Jean-Louis Borloo
m'a embauché comme directrice de la
politique de la ville en 91 à
Valenciennes et pendant cette année on a
commencé à travailler à imaginer ce
qu'elle est devenue le Grand projet de
ville puis l'ont rue ensuite donc j'ai
eu une rencontre technique et puis j'ai
mal de rénovation urbaine et Laurent
voilà et en fait pratiquer un mandat
local et servir quelqu'un comme
Jean-Louis c'est comprendre comment on
peut faire la politique autrement pour
les gens avec force détermination
conviction
et attachement aux concitoyens et aux
gens pour lesquels on est là et c'était
des paris impossibles à relever le
Valenciennois c'était 40 000 emplois
perdus en disant
usine nord et les mines fermées il a
réussi à mobiliser tout le monde il a
travaillé de façon transpartisane on a
essayé de chercher quel pourrait être
les solutions économiques humaines pour
emmener tout le monde et laisser
personne au bord de la route et
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup rien
industrialisation votre territoire
est-ce que vous considérez que le pari a
gagné mais écoutez il faut continuer
l'effort parce que l'industrie c'est un
éternel recommencement là maintenant il
faut une industrie propre verte et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui le
Valenciennois c'est rien industrialisé
avec Jean-Louis qui avait fait un gros
effort Toyota et d'autres mais il faut
continuer à aller vers le véhicule
propre etc et on voit bien que là le
plan industrie verte pour l'occasion
c'est quoi c'est accélérer une
réindustrialisation en profiter pour
qu'elle soit plus vertueuse et créer de
l'emploi le Nord s'est demi-600 000
habitants par exemple c'est une terre
d'industrie s'il y a pas d'industrie
comment mobilise-t-on et trouve-t-on des
solutions pour la grande partie de nos
populations qui sont des populations qui
ont une culture de l'industrie alors
très vite vous intégrez à l'école de la
chambre vous êtes entrés au Sénat en
2000 en 2001 pas
des dossiers techniques vous contribuez
à faire avancer des sujets comme le
revenu minimum d'activités ou
l'harmonisation des prestations sociales
et puis vous soutenez plusieurs textes
même s'ils ne sont pas issus de vos
rangs tant qu'ils vont dans la bonne
direction selon vous j'ai retrouvé un
extrait d'interview c'était autour des
années 2000 qui a pas de raison de
laisser certaines personnes sur le sur
le bord de la route sous prétexte que un
moment donné elles ont rencontré des
difficultés et que on peut très bien
avoir une volonté de développement
économique une fibre libérale et une
fibre sociale et l'un n'est pas
antinomique avec l'autre contraire c'est
tout à fait complémentaire ça a pas
changé
vous avez consciente vous avez défendu
des textes sociaux sociétaux vous auriez
pu être socialiste
quelques-uns disaient que j'étais
quelquefois plus social que les
socialistes et c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours incarné dans la famille d'idées
VDF udi j'ai toujours été celle qui
portait les questions les plus sociales
et qui est toujours défendu l'idée que
enfin moi je suis je conseille voilà on
est dans un univers une économie
libérale mais ça veut pas dire que ça se
fait au détriment des hommes et des
femmes et que la solidarité c'est pas
l'assistanat s'occuper de nos aînés
c'est pas de l'assistanat à aider des
gens qui sont qui ont perdu leur emploi
moi je viens d'un territoire ou quand on
est chômeur c'est pas parce qu'on n'a
pas envie de travailler quand il y a 40
000 emplois qui sont perdus comment on
fait pour accompagner les gens le temps
de retrouver une solution comment on
fait pour que justement ne tombe pas
dans l'assistance moi je suis contre
l'assistanat mais on ne peut pas dire
voilà celui-là il est au chômage c'est
pas possible c'est une honte et puis
qu'il travaille les solutions elles sont
pas elles se font pas en claquant des
doigts elles se trouvent pas en claquant
des doigts créons les conditions soyons
exigeants mais voilà voilà on doit
embarquer le plus grand nombre quand on
porte un projet politique quand on
s'engage en politique c'est pour essayer
de trouver une solution plus grand
nombre et de faire en sorte que les
richesses générées moi c'est ce que j'ai
toujours essayé de faire dans mon
territoire Jean-Louis il l'a fait moi je
l'ai fait quand j'étais 8 ans président
de l'Agglo mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
on développait l'industrie moi j'ai
requalifié cette zone industrielle on
attiré 170 km de fibre optique on
accueille beaucoup d'entreprises les
recettes fiscales générées par ça on les
investissaient dans leur rue on allait
accompagner nos cités minières en
difficulté et ça nous coûtait pas 1 euro
de fiscalité puisqu'on élargissait notre
assiette de revenus l'économie au
service du plus grand nombre et bien ça
fonctionne et ça coûte pas forcément si
on sait mettre tout ça en cohérence
oui je sais pas si on a le temps pour
aller en extrait on a le temps rapide un
dernier extrait donc quelques secondes
au milieu d'une dernière séance vous
sens émue donc là ça va être encore pire
vous a dit à vos collègues après plus de
20 ans au Sénat au regard
mes chers collègues je vous souhaite
plein de bonnes choses pour la suite et
voilà un petit pincement au cœur mais
plein de bonnes choses
il ne sait pas à la présidence de
joindre de ce joint aux applaudissements
de l'hémicycle pour autant je ressens la
même chose que ce que les collègues
viennent d'exprimer et je suis moi aussi
très émue de cette dernière intervention
c'est ça le Sénat des élus qui se ce que
je j'ai changé en aparté tout à l'heure
cette maison elle est formidable
ou sait-on en même temps défendre des
idées chevillées au corps
surtout les bancs on a des gens
empreintes conviction et de valeur mais
quand il s'agit de défendre des sujets
d'intérêt
d'intérêt généraux d'intérêt nationaux
on sait travailler les violences
conjugales le zan n'en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure
transpartisans des textes votés du Parti
communiste Cécile duckermann qui qui a
défendu le texte enfin quand on est sur
des sujets qui sont essentiels pour nos
collectivités nos territoires ou nos
populations on sait passer ces barrières
on sait travailler dans l'intérêt
général on sait travailler main dans la
main on sait être au combat quand ils le
font et il y a un respect mutuel et il y
a il y a ben voilà dans cette maison une
ambiance qui règne et qui donne envie de
s'investir de s'impliquer et qui permet
de trouver des solutions parce que on
arrive à aboutir et à porter des choses
qui finissent par l'emporter parce qu'on
a été solidaire et qu'on était dans le
vrai et qu'on n'a pas lâché et qu'on le
fait avec le terrain qu'on le fait
toujours à l'écoute de ce qui se passe
dehors on va continuer à parler de vos
combats Valérie Létard merci Audrey
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on
va en parler en allant chez vous dans le
Nord à Lille retrouver pierre Jérôme
monteneau bonjour Pierre Jérôme merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef ah oui oh c'est la
télévision locale et on va parler avec
vous dans des combats récents de Valérie
leters c'est la mise en place du Zéro
artificialisation nette
oui alors on parle d'une loi qui doit
limiter l'emprise des terres
artificialisacées c'est artificialisé
pardon donc bétonner sur l'industrie ou
bien sur le logement pour préserver les
terres agricoles et l'éternel vous
voulez assouplir vous avez combattu pour
assouplir cette loi parce que vous
trouvez que les maires et les
collectivités locales n'ont pas de
pouvoir ou pas assez de pouvoir pour
décider ce qui doit se construire ou pas
alors on a surtout fait cette loi parce
que en fait cette loi elle existe depuis
août 2021 c'est le zan en fait ce zéro
artificialisation net c'est le volet
aménagement et urbanisme de la grande
loi climat qui a été votée en août 2021
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait au Sénat aussi
non on fait des missions d'évaluation de
la loi comment elle se met en
application comment elle atterrit dans
les territoires et avec mon collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc et Cécile cuckermann
Jean-Claude Anglard et bien d'autres on
a fait cette mission commune
d'information cette mission
d'information et cette commission
spéciale pourquoi parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte après avoir questionné les
maires de France et les maires du Nord
et bien qu'il y avait un décalage énorme
entre en tout cas un décalage quand on
projetait le texte de loi c'est décret
d'application qui était quand même
extrêmement corseté on éteint on la
remontée qui nous était faite aussi bien
par les experts que par les
collectivités que par l'ensemble des
acteurs qui vont être concernés par ce
zéro artificialisation net il y allait
avoir un problème de mise en application
c'est un texte qui était très vertical
très arithmétique et qui corset
complètement la possibilité de nos
collectivités de faire un aménagement
vertueux de respecter bien évidemment
tous les principes qui disent attention
artificialisation pas de bétonnons pas
parce que on imperméabilise nos sols
attention aux inondations etc mais là on
était arrivé dans un texte qui était
tellement rigide tellement corseté avec
des objectifs inatteignables que ça
risque et ça risque et ça risque encore
si on ne surveille pas toujours comme
les laits sur le feu sa mise en oeuvre
parce qu'on a quelques souplesse qui ont
été apportées par notre texte notre
initiative parlementaire mais ce texte
il va transformer complètement les
possibilités des collectivités
d'accompagner les transformations de
leur commune comment faire du logement
avec fonciers comment accueillir des
entreprises avec moins de fonciers
comment mieux construire la ville
comment économiser ce foncier mais sans
pour autant que ce soit un coup d'arrêt
myotoir voilà ce que c'est que le zèbre
c'est les solutions qu'on a essayé
d'apporter je voulais faire sortir par
exemple les grands chantiers comme le
canal sendor ou l'arrivée d'une
industrie de batterie si on parle du
nord de cette comptabilité en fait ce
qui se passe je prendre un exemple
concret entre dans la décennie
précédente entre 2011 et 2021 bon les
hauts de France 16000 hectares ont été
mobilisés construits artificialisé pour
faire des
usines des logements etc la loi Zam elle
dit ce sera 8000 entre 2021 et 2031 2
fois moins c'est énorme et on doit
enlever de ces 8000 hectares tous les
grands projets industriels qui vont être
faits le problème c'est que dans les
hauts de France ça représente énormément
d'hectares ça veut dire que on les
retire de quelque chose qui est très
faible pour 6 millions d'habitants et
derrière il faut malgré tout construire
des logements des EHPAD il faut
construire des services publics il faut
construire et bien tout ce qui va avec
le développement économique il faut le
faire de façon plus vertueuse mais il
faut rester il faut quand même qu'il
reste collectivités rurale commune même
en travaillant sur une construction plus
densifiée des solutions et des
possibilités on peut réhabiliter nos
friches on a des friches mais ces
friches il faut des moyens pour les
requalifier aujourd'hui les moyens ne
sont pas encore au rendez-vous il y a
encore du travail au Sénat dans le
prochain budget il va falloir que le
gouvernement donne les moyens de réussir
Lausanne nous nous avons défendu un Zane
mais un Zane qui s'adapte au territoire
qui prend en compte la réalité de
terrain pierre Jérôme une dernière
question sur l'avenir politique de
Valérie l'état
du Sénat on vient de voir votre bilan
est-ce que vous allez rebondir sur
l'Europe avec les prochaines élections
européennes
en tout cas très sincèrement je ne sais
pas ce que je ferais demain j'ai un
mandat départemental vous le savez que
j'ai choisi parce que ces questions
sociales vous l'avez compris elles m'ont
toujours passionné
l'Europe je commence à me faire
tester par les uns et les autres parce
que forcément maintenant tout le monde a
compris que je ne repartais
c'est ce que vous nous dites en tout cas
on pose la question assez régulièrement
et j'avoue que je n'ai aucune idée sur
ce que je ferai demain j'ai envie de
m'impliquer en tout cas dans ce
département que j'adore sur des
questions qui me passionnent et où il y
a beaucoup de choses à remonter je
continue à m'engager évidemment en
politique à l'UDI aux côtés d'Hervé qui
est mon ami avec qui je partage beaucoup
de choses je suis présidente du Conseil
national je vais président du groupe
centriste Hervé Marseille président du
groupe tout à fait et continue à
m'impliquer surtout ces sujets et puis
on verra
nous pour une candidature aux
européennes quand même je je
accouchement je sais pas ce que je vais
faire je sais enfin on consulte sur des
organismes associés sur pas mal de
choses et très sincèrement j'ai quitté
le Sénat que j'adore parce que je pense
qu'il y a 20 ans que j'y suis je vous
avais compris que j'avais toujours
autant de passion et bien vu ce matin
mais mais je pense qu'il faut aussi sur
certains sujets sur lequel je me suis
toujours impliqué j'ai plein de
collègues qui ont une qui sont les mains
dans le cambouis qui sont élus locaux
qui ont une expérience une expertise
remarquable et j'espère qu'ils pourront
justement apporter de nouvelles idées
une façon d'aborder différentes
peut-être plus jeune peut-être plus en
phase ils ont vécu le covid ils ont dû
s'y coller ils ont leur propre
expérience moi je vous le ré aussi
montrer l'exemple et c'est pas parce que
je ne pourrais pas être élu ou ne pas me
représenter au sénatorial que je fais le
choix de ne pas y aller c'est parce que
je pense que de temps en temps faut
montrer aussi que tout en continuant à
s'engager on peut passer des témoins et
donner la possibilité à des collègues
d'apporter aussi de nouvelles idées
c'est possible et c'est pas parce que je
ne pouvais pas y retourner ou être élu
c'est un choix dur parce que j'aime ce
que je fais mais c'est aussi ça je
trouve
le respect de la fonction politique
c'est de prendre tout ça cheville au
corps ça veut pas dire ne plus
s'impliquer ça veut dire le faire
différemment et on sait que vous allez
être encore très présente merci Pierre
Jérôme Montenot merci d'avoir été avec
nous rédacteur en chef ah oui oh comme
le disait Laurence Rossignol Valérie
leter c'est pas mon rôle mais je voulais
vous remercier vraiment d'avoir été
toutes ces années présentes sur le
plateau de Public Sénat et notamment
dans cette émission et parler des
combats du quotidien des gens voilà
c'est ce qu'on cherche à faire dans
cette émission et c'est ce que vous êtes
venu faire à chaque fois merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Oriane et c'est toujours
un plaisir parce que comme je vous l'ai
dit on prend plaisir à venir ici on
parle des choses du quotidien c'est
fluide c'est bienveillant et en même
temps c'est exigeant c'est ce que les
gens veulent comprendre et sentir qu'il
y a de l'humanité dans ce qu'on fait
merci merci infiniment Valérie Létard et
bonne route évidemment pour la suite